[Music]
all right late tonight a federal judge
ordered Hunter Biden to appear in person
on October 3rd for his arraignment on
gun charges not by video as his lawyers
requested the investigation into Joe
Biden's son was a major part of today's
Congressional hearing with A.G Merrick
Garland
have you had personal contact with
anyone at FBI headquarters about the
hunter Biden investigation
ah
don't real I don't I don't recollect the
answer to that question but the FBI
works for the justice department it's uh
I'm sorry I'm sorry you don't recollect
you don't recollect whether you've
talked with anybody at FBI headquarters
about an investigation of the
president's son I I don't believe that I
did under oath today your testimony is
you have not had any discussions with Mr
Weiss about this matter under oath my
testimony today is that I promise that
the Senate I would not intrude in his
investigation
joining me now Congressman Tom Massey of
the Judiciary Committee Congressman you
know he doesn't remember conversations
about the president's son what went down
there you know usually he comes and he
says well it's long-standing FBI policy
not to comment on an ongoing
investigation well the job is
investigating so they're basically
saying they won't comment on anything
but today he had he'd just forgotten
everything he didn't know he wasn't
there couldn't remember well he's
someone of impeccable memory I mean he's
one of the he was one of the smartest
jurists on the DC circuit uh so smart
that the Democrats wanted to put him on
the Supreme Court
um he's not you know Bob Mueller kind of
having you know struggles perhaps
intellectually this guy is kind of
Johnny on the spot so I'm not following
that I I didn't either we didn't buy it
I didn't believe it but one of the
themes that came out of this hearing
today was that there's two tiers of
Justice there's a dual system here and
the and the reason Hunter Biden tried to
get his arraignment by video is he
thought he could he's gotten special
treatment the whole time by this doj do
you think that the gun charge issue is
kind of a fig Leaf though to kind of get
people off the scent of what really is
going on here which is influence
peddling perhaps U.S foreign policy
changed or altered or some some type of
effect on it because of the money Trail
going 100 by oh absolutely this is the
one charge that doesn't go back to Joe
Biden you know the big guy the big guy
wasn't involved in the gun charge so
we'll we'll charge him with that whereas
and and then also some of these tax uh
charges or some some of the charges they
slow walked them so that the statute of
limitations ran out for the period of
time where the big guy was involved so
that if you do go into the other charges
that you know he supposedly pled to they
weren't during this period of barisma
and Joe Biden as vice president so that
that's another thing they did they only
want to charging for the things we're
that aren't connected to the big guy
they wall it off now Garland is outraged
Congressman that anyone would challenge
his prosecutors
what is dangerous is when anyone singles
out a career prosecutor or a career FBI
agent and we know as a matter of fact
that that kind of singling out has led
to threats this is a concern across the
board
so you can't question uh someone with
that much power
in in a situation where there's at least
the appearance of and I mean at the very
least the appearance of a conflict of
interest yeah part of that's part of the
job look when he talked about threats
and tried to get some sympathy we all
looked at each other on the Deus and
we're like wait we get threats every day
as members of Congress like if you're in
the public eye but you are accountable
and um we they should be questioned and
that's what we were doing there or
trying to do there Congressman on the um
what's that on your pocket there oh this
yeah what was that because we get a
close-up of that can we move into that
that's blinding me what is that oh so
it's oh it's a you know I have an
engineering degree and I realize that
some of my colleagues have pacemakers
but what they really need is an anxiety
maker so I display the debt to them
every second I got 33 trillion 65
billion 792 million and then I can't
read the rest it's too fast but it's
it's meant to provide anxiety to my
colleagues I'm sort of the skunk at the
garden party there in Congress but it's
needed they need to know what two
trillion more this year right yeah keep
keep going with Ukraine no no ended side
Congressman great to see you thank you
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else